with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to all of them so if you didn't get
to see build mobile apps with flutter
and Google Maps then stay tuned because
here's the rewind as a developer
relations engineer I often hear from
developers that they need to develop
mobile experience for their customers
faster and they want their app to be a
joy to use flutter allows developers to
write once and deploy everywhere saving
time and money
by developing for both Android and iOS
using one development team and one
codebase developers usually love coding
with flutter as we empower them with
stateful hot reload which gets their
changes onto their device just by
hitting save in their editors which is
exactly what our talk at cloud next was
all about here is a quick montage of the
app I built live on stage in San
Francisco mapping out the ice cream
stores around the conference center we
started as always with hello world
then we connect Google cloud fire store
to get a list of ice cream stores next
we expose the list of these stores using
ListView builder and add a Google map to
enable us to visualize where the stores
are we then utilize Google Maps web
services to retrieve photos for the
stores and as one final flourish we
build a carousel to enable users to
swipe through the list of stores easily
to watch the full talk check out the
link in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]